all right so Yellow Jackets season two
is almost upon us but for the sake of
you me everyone else that forgot what
the heck happened in season one of this
survivalist Supernatural Twist and Turn
filled show let's recap everything that
went down as a nice refresher along with
all of the questions and potential
theories we may still have so strap in
for this Supernatural walkthrough of
season one of Yellowjackets I'm your guy
to Jared this is an amazing series I'm
not gonna lie I just binged all of this
so let's do this alright so kicking
things off pun intended Yellow Jackets
follows a New Jersey high school girls
soccer team as they make it to Nationals
but on the way their plane crashes in
the wilderness the end I mean that's
kind of the gist of it right okay okay
so yellow jackets core story is told
through a dual timeline and to make
things easier for this recap let's focus
on the younger years wilderness us who
survives and who doesn't first before we
jump into the present day where everyone
is adults dealing with their own
Shenanigans so episode 1 opens on a
frightened woman trying to escape for
her life in a frozen frigid Tundra but
falls into a hidden Spike pit with a
mysterious character looking over their
lifeless body we're then introduced to
the main Yellow Jackets players who are
then going to follow through this wacky
Wilderness Adventure Jackie is
essentially the ring leader and captain
of the other girls on the Yellowjackets
team very popular pretty dating the
stereotypical popular jock boy named
Jeff her best friend is Shauna who is
always there for Jack he pretty much
does anything and everything that she
wants to Natalie or Nat is the burnout
involved with you know drugs and alcohol
said to be more on the promiscuous side
of the team but it's discovered she very
much has a troubled home life Tasia is
the competitive one on the team wanting
to win at any and all costs even
injuring one of the Freshman girls who
she sees not fit for the championship at
Nationals other members include Misty
the socially awkward team equipment
manager who is very much shunned from
the group because of her weirdness and
lastly Vanessa the yellowjack is goalie
and Lottie another player on the team
who is later revealed to have
schizophrenia the plane is ready to go
to Nationals with the entire
Yellowjackets team along with two pilots
head coach and his two sons Travis and
Javi and the assistant coach Ben Scott
however halfway to their Nationals
dreams the plane crashes in the barren
Wilderness and cuts to seven mysterious
figures now eating the same frightened
woman in the opening one of them removes
their cloak to reveal it is Misty
insinuating the others are yellow
jackets and have been slowly eating one
another to survive we now go back to the
crash seeing a handful of girls head
coach and the two pilots who did not
survive the crash they scrambled to gain
composure and bandage up one another
with Misty using her survival skills
amputating coach Scott's lower leg which
was pinned and mangled by wreckage later
Misty hears some of the other girls
praising her knowledge and survival
skills praise that she's never received
before in her life and she kind of likes
it this delusional thinking though
drives her to smash and dismantle the
plane's Black Box locator halting any
sort of rescue efforts that have been on
the way bizarre symbols are then seen
carved on trees here or there as the
girls come upon an abandoned cabin with
supplies and serving as a shelter
everyone but Lottie is ecstatic about
the dwelling but with her claiming that
the cabin kind of has this like hella
bad juju to it potassia chalks it up as
lottie's schizophrenia being heightened
because she no longer has her meds
however Lottie May actually be onto
something or have some sort of foresight
as there's a flashback of her
theoretically seen a car accident before
it happens saving herself and her
parents her mother believes that she may
have psychic abilities while her father
isn't too sold on it later that evening
tasius swear she hears some rustling up
in the attic upon investigation she
discovers a scared elodie staring at a
corpse of a man chained to a chair and
close to him carved into the floor are
the same weird symbols that have been
seen a couple of times on the trees in
the wilderness amongst the supplies in
the cabin a rifle is found by coach
Scott knowing he wouldn't be much help
hunting because the fact that he's
missing the leg he has the teens compete
in a friendly Marksman contest proving
Natalie and Travis to be the best shots
tasking them with essentially hunting
duties one of the first things Travis
does while the hunting with natto is
head back to the plane crash retrieving
his father's ring to give to Javi as
remembrance a handful of girls discover
an old puddle jumper plane buried in the
wooded areas that seemingly still works
when Laura Lee turns it on narrowly
almost killing a couple of their
teammates Laura Lee's goal is to read as
much of the plane's manual as she can
fly that some beach out of there and get
some help now crazy believe me crazy but
at this point they are running out of
Hope on the other hand a Lottie
discovers some more of the weird cryptic
symbols laced throughout the woods and
believes that the woods have power over
them this is why the man couldn't leave
in the plane the forest and higher
Powers would not permit it the
supernatural elements continue as the
girls then have a seance in the attic
for fun placing candles and all of the
symbols on the floor calling to any and
all Spirits out there now things take a
dark twist as Lottie is possessed by
something speaking in a French dialect
stating they must bread blood whatever
it is wants blood smashing her head into
the pane of glass of the window it's
quickly realized by Tasia that Shana is
pregnant because she hasn't wirelessly
synced up with the other girls during
that time of the month and a big reveal
here Shawna got pregnant by Jeff
Jackie's boyfriend Shauna attempts to
keep the secret from her best friend but
the poking and prodding and lying can
only go so far Lottie continues to have
strange visions of which one is a deer
with bloodied antlers this strange
Vision then comes true as Travis and
that return with some much needed meat
upon slicing open the deer though the
insides are completely rancid and
infected with maggots they can't they
just can't eat this with Coach Scott
alluding to sick animals because the
seasons are changing meaning winter is
coming knowing they are running low on
options Tasia and a handful of other
girls gear up to venture out to
hopefully find some help then at the
last minute begrudgingly says she's
gonna go with her because her and Tasia
are now romantically involved they love
one another and she wouldn't be able to
live with herself if something bad
happened to her before leaving though
Lottie gives van a bone from the sick
deer telling her to keep it on her
person as it'll bring her and the group
protection with the group very much
being smaller Shauna's pregnancy secret
is pride out of her by Jackie but Shauna
lies saying it's a Randy another dude in
high school with them he's actually the
father instead of the actual father Jeff
Natalie and Travis at this time also
have become romantically involved but
after being embarrassed while trying to
get it up and go to Pound Town Travis
kind of creates a rift between the pair
another of lottie's Visions comes true
as the river tossier's group tries to
drink from is a deep red and smells
horribly Lottie warned them about a
river of blood and a cloud of red smoke
but Asia chalks it up as just a weird
coincidence don't think anything of it
later that night Tasia fails to stay
awake on the first watch resulting in
her sleep climbing yes she climbs up a
tree while sleeping while the others are
attacked by a pack of wolves Tasia
shoots the flare gun red smoke just like
Lottie said saving van but she is
severely hurt mangled face and is
unconscious the group assumes she's dead
lighting her up in a ceremonial pyre but
van regains Consciousness at the last
second this causes everyone to return
back to the cabin with the others
stitching up Van's face allowing her to
Live Another Day Laura Lee all studied
up on her flying manual takes it upon
herself to fly that plane out to finally
find some help obviously running out of
ideas everyone agrees with this clearing
a path for her to fly out of the woods
Laura Lee is able to get airborne things
look like they are in the clear oh nope
nope and the plane is on fire and boom
goes the dynamite yeah the plane
explodes and they are yet again as
helpless as ever pessimistic Jackie
suggests that they have one final party
because no one knows how much longer
they'll actually survive this party is
coined at Dooms coming because it's like
homecoming but you know Doom anyway they
all start tripping balls because Misty's
secret mushrooms had accidentally been
added into the stew resulting in like a
way far out their time man under the
influence Shauna almost slits Travis's
neck under the authority of Lottie but
luckily Natalie and Jackie stop him in
the nick of time during this craziness
though Shauna told Javi to run and the
next morning he is nowhere to be seen
just
hungover is all hell the lifeless girls
post party mode spring to Life as a bear
saunters into their camp and basically
just offers itself up to sacrifice as
Lottie stabs it in the head with a knife
killing it Lottie is now seen as more of
a deity by the group as her Visions
continue to become true
Jackie the supposed captain of the
yellow jackets now brings up everything
that has happened the night before along
with Shauna actually being pregnant with
Jeff's baby yeah that's right Jackie
stole Shauna's diary and learned of all
of the juicy gossip however all of this
actually backfires on Jackie instead of
getting to play the victim she's instead
seen as the problem by the collective
because she just isn't pulling her
weight around camp this causes Jackie to
throw one big ol hissy fit instead
sleeping outside by a small makeshift
fire while the others enjoy the warmth
and security of the cabin however to
everyone's surprise it had snowed that
night before and Jackie who decided to
Camp outside had frozen to death
seemingly now a ghost or a spirit Jackie
sees who we can assume is the chained up
guy in the Attic welcoming her into the
Afterlife the final bit of past
Wilderness footage is Lottie sacrificing
what appears to be the Bear's heart up
to a stump in the forest not only this
but Misty and Van appear to be her
trusty servants in this ritual kneeling
to the offering and stating
[Music]
which means shed the blood my beautiful
friends and as it begins to snow Lottie
continues with I let the darkness set us
free
now jumping ahead in time present day
introduces us to Jessica a reporter
trying to gather information on what
really happened all of those years ago
in the wilderness as we see her
interviewing characters adjacent to the
core Yellowjackets who were in the
wilderness this leads to very vague
stories all being very similar without
any of them actually revealing what
happened Jessica approaches the core
Yellowjackets members starting with
Shauna who tells her she's already told
everyone the entire story there's
nothing new just leave her alone
obviously this is not true but we do
know Shauna made it out alive along with
Natalie who has just finished up her
time at a drug and alcohol rehab
facility but is still haunted by visions
of the gruesome things that they had to
do in the wilderness and her father's
abuse the reporter showing up to Shawna
frightens her a bit causing her to meet
up with Tasia to discuss what is
happening and make sure no one's
actually spilled the bean means they are
still sticking to the same narrative all
of those years ago Tasia the third
member to be revealed to have actually
survived is now running for New Jersey
State Senate and insists that she hasn't
spoken to anyone she wouldn't want to
jeopardize her potential office run and
is grateful for shawna's heads up Misty
is also revealed to have made it now
working as a care facility nurse but
unlike Shauna and Tasia she isn't in
touch with any of the former cannibal
companions we we see Shauna lives a
mundane Suburban life married to
Jackie's former boyfriend Jeff with a
daughter of their own on the way home
Shauna accidentally rear-ends an artist
named Adam Martin they exchange
information for insurance purposes
elsewhere Natalie breaks into Misty's
home threatening her with a rifle
because she assumes Misty sent her a
postcard featuring the same strange
symbol that they've seen time and time
again back in the wilderness but to
Natalie's surprise Misty received the
same similar postcard only days before
insisting they are looking for the same
person the two have a drink and discuss
who of the remaining survivors could be
behind the postcards showing that Misty
has been keeping tabs on all of them and
revealing the reporter Jessica might not
be who she actually says she is Natalie
discovers Travis's new identity tries to
phone him but unfortunately he hangs up
on her the next day Misty and Natalie
try to track down Travis breaking into
his home thinking his place of
employment may be where he's at but the
two are then arrested for trespassing
but then released by Kevin tan Natalie's
best friend back in the day and who they
actually had spoken to at the bar the
night before Shauna spirals a bit as she
thinks Jeff is having an affair with
sketchy text messages and even following
him to a hotel Shauna has all but
confirmed her suspicions when she
receives a call from Adam about getting
her vehicle fixed the two have a drink
at the same Hotel bar only for Shawna to
see Jeff leaving with a beautiful blonde
woman yet even more evidence Jeff is
getting some strange on the side this
drives Shauna to say [__] it and become
sexually involved with Adam Natalie and
Misty Fresh Out The Slammer continue
their search for Travis going to his
place of work only to find him hanging
from a forklift in an parent suicide
they leave before the police show up
Misty believes that there's more to this
though because when they were at his
place she had found a note and took it
that stated tell Nat she was right but
Natalie hasn't a damn clue what she was
right about Natalie asked Kevin if he
can help her with the whole Travis
situation because she believes he was
murdered it wasn't accidental soon after
agreeing to help Natalie sees that Misty
has been following her obviously upset
Misty has the same reaction though
towards Jessica who has been spying on
Natalie and Misty telling her to back
off she doesn't know what she's getting
involved in Kevin lets Natalie know that
Travis's toxicology report was clean
essentially ruling out him ending his
own life in her mind she enlists Misty
once again to help hack into Kevin's
emails to find out more about Travis's
report and history well Misty updates
Shauna on Travis's fate the next
notices her doggo barking erratically
only to look out of her apartment window
and see a wolf yes a wolf growling
outside in the street the magic of CGI
friends as she goes down there to
confront the wolf but nothing is there
thinking these hallucinations may be
tied to her current campaign she notices
someone has vandalized their front door
in red paint with the word
spill meaning spill the tea spill the
details about what really happened those
25 years ago later though Tasia finds
the same red paint under her son's bed
they confront him about the paint and
the graffiti but he insists that it was
a scary woman who was perched in a tree
outside of his window that did it
a liar but that is the story he sticks
with Misty is able to find out more
about Travis's death through Kevin's
emails her and Natalie discover candle
wax drippings around Travis's crime
scene that create the same mysterious
cryptic symbol they all had discovered
in the woods 25 years ago but why why is
this symbol at the crime scene who's
responsible for this did the mysterious
power of the woods track him down
Natalie ropes and Tasia to see if she
has any insight into this strange
occurrence she doesn't however the two
received startling text blackmailing
them for cash threatening to release
secrets of their time in the wilderness
if they do not comply Misty instantly
finds out about this blackmailing
because she had set up a hidden camera
at Natalie's to see if she could you
know actually trust her Shawna is roped
in by the pair informing her of the
postcards in blackmail but Shauna
insists she has nothing to do with it
she knows nothing because she never
received a postcard a whole new unhinged
side of Misty is shown as we see Jessica
the nosy reporter is now gagged and
bound in Misty's basement Misty warned
her to back off and well Misty wasn't
around as she now has her as her own
little prisoner misery style Shauna
Natalie and Tasia gear up for the
blackmail drop but not before it's
revealed Tasia is chomping on some dirt
outside of her house it's revealed the
same sleepwalking from our teenage years
is flaring up once again because of
stress causing her to do strange things
like eat dirt without any recollection
meaning that the creepy tree woman that
her son said was responsible for the
paint was actually her but like in a
dream state as Tasia cleans herself up
Jessica still held captive in Misty's
basement reveals she was actually hired
by Tasia the reason was to protect her
political run she wouldn't want any of
them to speak out and ruin the past what
really happened you know basically
divulge what they were doing but now
Misty knows that none of them have the
blackmail drop goes as horribly as you
would have hoped resulting in Natalie
taking a shot at the mysterious
blackmailer and the blackmailer ditching
the tracker that they had tried to hide
in the bag Mission failed as Shauna
returns home only to find Adam waiting
outside of her place obviously foolish
Behavior because Jeff or her daughter
Cali could have seen him but Adam is
smitten with Shauna instead making out
drives the two inside to fool around but
Jeff comes back home resulting in Shauna
having to hide Adam in the closet
narrowly being caught the next morning
Cali finds Adam's wallet behind the
couch livid that her mother would bring
him into their house right under her dad
Jeff's nose like that Misty continues
spy on Natalie rushing over to her
apartment to stop her from relapsing
obviously Natalie is pissed as all hell
but Misty informs her that there's more
to Travis's death a mysterious person
had cleared out his bank accounts after
his death meaning there's a deeper
connection to who might actually be at
play Natalie blackmails a banker who she
had met in rehab telling her to look
into Travis's bank account and to find
out who actually emptied it Shauna not
only discovers glitter in her closet
connecting it to the night before that
they chased the blackmailers through the
different department stores but the safe
where she keeps her Diaries was emptied
as well her only conclusion is that Adam
was responsible he was the last one in
the closet and Cali added that there was
no trace of Adam anywhere online who is
the guy actually Shauna storms over to
Adam's Place For answers suspecting him
of selling her and the other Secret she
then stabs him in the gut resulting in
his death in a wild Twist of events
though Shauna stows the knife in her
safe only to discover the Diaries are
back in the safe and then Jeff yes her
husband Jeff was actually the one behind
the blackmailing he was about to lose
the furniture store the blonde woman
from the hotel was actually a lone shark
he'd owed money to and thought
blackmailing Tasia was the easiest way
to get money that quickly of course
things spiral as Shauna was wrong about
the affair wrong about the blackmailing
her and Jeff though agree to blame
everything on Adam and just wash their
hands of the situation Shauna lets the
others know that Adam was the
blackmailer and she is taking care of it
they needed to dispose of his body
though in all of the evidence that may
be connected to him or any sort of
connection they of course call up the
ringer Misty to help with this because
she obviously has a knack for this sort
of thing with Adam being revealed to be
the man with the plan Misty decides to
let Jessica finally leave and be set
free however Misty has the last final
evil smirk by filling Jessica's
cigarettes with a lethal dose of
fentanyl poisoning her as she drives
away Tasia being down in the polls has
sort of admitted defeat but the
newscaster States the results are much
closer than initially anticipated
resulting in Tasia winning the New
Jersey senate campaign as the winning
results play out Simone tossia's wife
discovers something horrific hidden in
the basement vent what looks like a
ritualistic altar there is their son's
broken doll candles the head and heart
of their missing dog finished with a
blood smattered drawing of the same
cryptic symbol we've seen time and time
again in the wilderness Natalie losing
hope that Travis's dad had more to it
and Mitch defeat and is ready to end her
own life because of this however
mysterious cult-like members break into
her apartment and kidnap her all of them
are wearing small little pendants
sporting the same ritualistic symbol
from the woods as Natalie is then thrown
into a van and driven away lastly as
this is happening Susie the banker from
earlier leaves a voicemail she's scared
of what Natalie has dragged her into
because she believes her Snoopy now has
people following her too the end of the
call has her asking who the heck is
Lottie Matthews meaning Lottie and the
symbol are still very much alive in the
present day but why why does she want
Natalie and how is she connected to
Travis folks that is all of season one
hopefully this catches you up on the
craziness of what I hope season 2 is
because there is far more questions than
answers at this point with a lot of
things still needing those answers like
where is Hobby did he survive die was he
actually Adam what does the weird symbol
actually mean what really happened with
Travis and who the heck is the no eyes
man who's just creeping about in the
background of a couple of scenes
uh no no no thank you sir Anyway season
two is almost here and I'd love to hear
your thoughts on Yellow Jackets are you
geared up for season two like me and
what sort of theories do you have
Brewing about any and all things and all
that you know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
the Superman collection on the 15th of
April and all you gotta do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop your thoughts on Yellowjackets
in the comments below we picked the
comments at random at the end of every
single month in the winners of last
month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other great videos Mandalorian
the last of us we've been cranking them
out but with all of that out of the way
thank you for your constant support I'm
very excited for season two of
Yellowjackets I've been Jared I'll see
in the next one take care and Buzz Buzz
baby